OK, let's hear from some folks in the audience
taking calls via discord at David Pakman Dotcom
Discord joined the community on discord.
It's free, I think about 11000 people now on the
discord, maybe approaching 12000. It's a great
thing. All right. Let's see what's on people's
minds, starting with let's go to Grayson from
Seattle, Grayson from Seattle. You're on the air.
Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes, I can. Great.
So I was wondering what you think the future holds
for conservative commentators like
Stephen Crowder or centrist and I have
centrist in quotes, commentators like
Tim Pool especially was radio silence.
And I was just wondering what kind of content
can they even produce now that all the darlings
of terrorist inciters or sympathizers.
So you're saying Crowder has
been radio silent? I didn't know that.
Yeah. After January 6th, he was pretty silent,
like like one or two low tweets. I think he
started doing his show recently again. I mean,
I don't like watching it, so I haven't
looked at it too much. But I mean, I just
don't know what kind of argument he has anymore.
You know, it's I mean, I know what the argument
will be. And we're already you all you have to do
is look at Fox News and on a Newsmax to understand
that there is still a very much alive, radical
right sort of perspective. And that includes
going back to all of the tired old tropes. Laura
Ingram did it on Fox News. I think it was Monday
night where she did, you know, the segment about
the Biden insurrection. And he's welcoming on
dangerous undocumented immigrants and brown
people and all this stuff. And here's the thing
that may be so tired and boring to you and I who
are now looking to see what will Joe Biden get
done and can we start restoring the reputation
of the country. But you can do really well
as an individual show or channel with a tiny
slice of the American public, because there's
three hundred and thirty one million people in
the country. So I think that they're going to
do just fine. I mean, to people, to people like us
who now we just laugh when we see them go back to
their same talking points, OK, we're not in their
audience, but I think they're going to do fine.
Yeah, fair enough, I think you're right,
and then I had a quick Argentinian Lingoa
question, if you don't mind. Oh, sure, of
course. So I put my Argentino, RNC chair
Belluardo to each other, right?
Can I get away with saying that
in a friendly way or is that a bit
too aggressive to say to my friend?
I think it's fine. I mean, it's so it's not
you know, it's not a thing where you just
kind of saying kind of like, hey, you prick, you
know, it's not it's not racially discriminatory.
It's not you're not picking on any particular
religion or anything like that. I think it's fine.
And it'll show you to be sort of like an insider
to the lingo. I think you're fine with that.
Perfect. Well, I think this might
have been a perfect call. This was
a perfect phone call. Absolutely.
Thank you, Grayson from Seattle.
Great to hear from you and
hope to hear from you again.